had a good run there for a while now
it's alright
bombings and people thrown in cages like
animals oh I know you can forget the
killer robots everywhere
so yeah let's knock on a bit [ __ ] it's
up to us to take our city back yes can't
do it alone we need to recruit a
resistance I know what you're thinking
where do we start
open your eyes and take a look around
look a look at him
no not him him Foreman mi5 duty never
ends they can get anywhere and erase
anyone sue got kicked out of Oxbridge
robotics school for teaching him to
reproduce
[Music]
and that fellow over there probably left
come on drama me he'll crack your skull
just been looking at funny
[Music]
this had better be [ __ ] good and
allow me to introduce you to the
deadliest of the love this is not out
she's experienced like I said you can
recruit anyone and all me bloody anyone
him/her everyone is a secret weapon find
them recruit them
build the resistance
[ __ ] this world
[Music]
watchdogs Legion available March 6 2020
check out the watchdogs Legion 101
trailer